this is Startalk we're talking about
going to Mars and Abed like humans going
to Mars humans going to Mars curious
about the movie that you've mentioned a
few times already John the Martian and I
understand that like Andy weir did he
get advice from NASA at some point like
it seems to be quite realistic no I
think he talked to the scientists
engineers at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory there in Pasadena not far
from where he lives so I I think he got
a lot of first-class advice on sending
robots to Mars and what it was like to
send people to Mars what what did you
get asked that question about that movie
almost all the time you know I whenever
I speak there I know about gravity or
the Martian that I like it and from my
perspective John I just like look see a
space movie I just try to look and see
if the astronaut was cool you know
George Clooney was cool yeah you know
whatever yeah you know it's a lot of
science things wrong with it but as long
as George Clooney look cool that was
fine
Matt Damon was cool he got stuck with an
antenna in the chest and sold himself up
no I wouldn't I would look at that I
would go and I would scream but people
think because I'm an astronaut I would
very coolly pull it out of my chest and
sew myself up Matthew McConaughey
you know I that guy needed he needed a
drink he was a little bit too intense I
was in a little disappointed with that
with that movie interstellar because but
I just heard the way the the the
astronauts portrayed if he's cool or he
or she's cool I'm good with it but John
what did you think about the movie to
March I'm sure you get questions all the
time about that what was your opinion
well I enjoyed it I thought it was
probably the best space movie since 2001
and we can argue about whether it was
better than 2001 my wife says she
prefers not to go to space movies with
me because all I do is huff and puff and
roll my eyes audibly during it usually
during the entire movie but she said I
would buy I behave myself well this time
in fact the only snide comment that
either was made was was one she made
during one of the the climactic EBA
scenes she noticed the astronaut was not
tethered to the spacecraft and she said
that would never happen
at that possibly how could they make a
movie with that in it so I but otherwise
I thought it was a lot of fun I you know
and EDA has said that the the opening
event you know the the the wind that
blows everything around and causes the
problem couldn't happen on Mars the
atmosphere is too thin and the dust is
not sandy grainy granular like that it's
more like the texture of smoke particles
and he said I actually I asked him that
question during a Q&A one time he said
yes I know but I needed to start the
movie somehow that's how I chose to do
it
did you just show up at a Q&A like a
regular citizen like he didn't know that
you had all this he actually came to
Johnson Space Center and then series a
series of book talks and QAS from all of
its nerds so he was very well prepared
for the audience and we all loved him
yeah John was a plant yeah but that was
right and Eevee acing the space or see
the end soon as you mention that my my
son and I saw it together and he said
the same thing I was dad what kind of
spacewalk anymore my son Peeta my son
was picked up on it was very
unprofessional the way they were
untethered at the end you were like but
wasn't it cool when he pulled the
antenna right I said yeah don't worry
about that Matt Damon was a cool
astronaut
this one's approved it must be great
like PR vice like that's like my you
know when you see great movie about
space like it makes you think highly of
NASA for some reason think so what do
you think I think that was that was good
for us wasn't it I agree we got we
certainly used it for a lot of publicity
we we tried to link a lot of the one
year mission space station work to it
and and things like that so yeah that
was great
Johnny but there's also the serious part
to what the movie portrayed which was
how do you keep a crew alive now he was
in a survival situation but still there
there must be a lot of parallels that
with the work you're doing what you saw
in that movie right is food and water
and life support and so on yeah exactly
well I mean the food was was one of the
actually a potato was like another
Supporting Actor in the whole movie and
your buddy in the whole history of
Ireland's but but Mike your pal have you
heard what don pettit said about
potatoes in space though Mike no don don
petty
is one of my best friends oh and a very
entertaining guy in a genius very rare
for an astronaut let me add yeah did he
say this time you've Don Pettit said he
has never seen a potato on the space
station or the shuttle that it was not
sliced and had its eyes cut out so
there's no way a potato on this in space
would have been able to grow and produce
more potatoes but don don did actually
grow stuff in space and they are growing
stuff on his baby but i'm don grew his
own he grew a sunflower and he grew up
squash yeah that it was kind of on his
own but he did his own little expert but
they have grown also lettuce on the
space station seeds we fly up to do that
that kind of research to eventually lead
to growing I didn't think it was like an
accidental some astronauts might do
things because they're interested on
their own experiments this was the the
lettuce was a real growing and lettuce
was a real project yeah that they had
and was successful so you can't to grow
your own food in space yeah yeah the
results and then eat the results and
then they're good hopefully this is
Startalk
you